the Joe Rogan experience you know where
the rubber hits the road with conspiracy
theories right now Jeffrey Epstein oh
yeah that's the where the rubber hits
the road was where people that are not
conspiratorial and minded we're like
wait what the [ __ ] is going on what all
the cameras were bad all the guy was on
suicide watch he tried to commit suicide
and then they're like well don't do that
again and then he did it like if you
talk to people that have been locked up
they take away everything man you've
been on suicide watch
they [ __ ] take away everything mm-hmm
and you find this guy he's got a broken
neck and he hung himself like how how
did he hang himself can we see the video
footage all sorry the cameras are broke
I think handle yourself is wicked hard
it's not easy oh yeah it's not easy it's
not easy when you're in a jail and they
tell you better Jim no no I was only in
jail overnight but I mean they if you're
on suicide watch man they make it hard
for you to kill yourself that's you and
if you're is that what suicide watch
means yes no watch thank you they watch
you so you can't kill yourself again
that's they watch you every 30 minutes
what the [ __ ] was this psychologist
thinking that took this guy off suicide
watch literally a couple of weeks after
he tried to commit suicide if someone
tried to commit suicide you know not
speaking as who a guys had friends
commit suicide they're [ __ ] thinking
about it for years man some of them they
go back and forth days okay some of them
some of them just do yes some of them
just do that but when someone does
actively try it they're not going to
just be fine while they're in [ __ ]
prison awaiting trial for having sex
with kids it seems like Geoffrey
Epstein's life was gonna get really
worse from what it was a few months
before could be or other people's lives
are gonna get really worse because
Jeffrey Epstein is now in jail and
they're digging deep into his past and
well I only flew with him 26 times 26
times it ain't a lot of times to fly
with a guy I don't understand what the
big deal is we flew in a jet we rode a
bus together
he was on the buy my bike do you know do
you know people that know Jeffrey
Epstein yes yeah yeah I did
me too and a lot of them
it really was that talk to him well a
little bit there's many people that feel
like he was an agent and that he was
trying to compromise people and that's
one of the things about this whole
Lolita Island thing is that they would
compromise people they would compromise
people by having a bunch of young girls
or very sexy who were hired to go and
flirt and maybe even have sex with
people and that these people were young
these girls were like 17 underage may
perhaps underage some places perhaps not
underage other places but incredibly
embarrassing and you know for the people
in agent compromise for whom who knows I
mean there's a lot of lot of thoughts
but that's one of the things about when
he got arrested the the was that the
prosecutor whoever was a cut in the deal
literally was quoted as saying I was
told he's above my pay grade
yeah and that he was intelligence that's
the quote really the teller just think
try to find that quote yeah try to find
that quote yes the guy said this was
when he gave him the lenient sentence
many years ago Wow for something no one
seems to know how he got his money
well the [ __ ] 70 million dollar
penthouse that he had in Manhattan was
given to him right given to him yeah who
the [ __ ] gives someone a 70 million
dollar house well I was kind of hoping
you would to me I don't have one okay if
I have a bunch of all I give you one I
got a run here to give us seventy
million dollar house ah you were told
wrong yeah yeah I mean I think the guy
it's I think they're look I've talked to
people many times that work for
intelligence agencies and there's a lot
of weird [ __ ] that they do and one of
the things that they do to compromised
people as they get them involved in
weird stuff that could be very bad for
them it comes out and then they have
influence of this person and if you got
a guy with a voracious sexual appetite I
mean there's a few those fellows out
there and you know hey I'm at our office
now I'm gonna [ __ ] hanging out having
a good time with Jeffrey and we're just
flying around I mean come on man it's
it's it's highly likely one of the guys
that I know that knew him was also a
freak like a sexual freak and I'm like
okay I think I think I see a pattern
here
this it's very likely that that's what
was going on
this guy was compromising people and
probably absolutely a sex addict himself
and I believe all the women would say
all the horrible things that he did to
them and hired them for things and had
underage girls do sexual things with him
it's probably true probably true he's
probably a [ __ ] up twisted dude but
many people that are involved even in
good things get compromised like there's
many people that work for the CIA that
were legitimate CIA operatives who wound
up selling drugs there's a lot of this
happens people go sideways people get
involved in shady activities that are
cops there's cops that wind up doing
illegal things they signed on to be a
cop to be a person who's gonna serve and
protect and be involved in the community
and slowly but surely they get
compromised and they get involved in
illegal activity and next thing you know
they're corrupt it happens
and then sometimes people [ __ ]
suicide themselves and the people that
that I know that knew him it was they
weren't even aware of the seedy stuff
going on so uh and of course that's
gonna be true too
well he was that would be a hundred
percent he was also a champion of
science yeah I mean yes isn't he
but that's the thing about people they
can be really good sure in some ways and
horrible in other ways this idea that
people are binary or one or a zero is
nonsense yeah there's really good people
that do terrible things there's really
terrible people
that also do good things